all of the tmg studios content is in one
place every podcast every episode every
bonus episode all ad free and you can
access it for just six dollars a month
with a membership to tmgstudios.tv
i think drake has some really
unlistenable yeah yeah are you kidding
me like yeah yeah he takes the cake for
weird ass lines
yeah every rapper jack has just fallen
victim to
what happens when you have too much cool
but he does the same thing in [ __ ] uh
what's popping yeah in the remix give me
neutron i'm a young boy genius something
some some give her that penis yeah that
to me penis is super unlistenable penis
that's simon
are you wrapping in medical terms no i'm
i'm arguing back on penis it's hilarious
to say penis it's i but that's not
listenable
no it is
yo there oh man hold on let me look up
this group
there's a group that breesley bruin was
in juggernauts they have a song
and
kid
risley bruin is raving about like
drinking with a girl
and just he goes you like pina colada
like
yeah yeah yeah
and that's the first time i heard penis
used in like an effective way okay and
like rap music i'm like
that was hilarious i respect that that
was tough yeah you like penis a lot of
okay so i'm gonna respectfully
i'm gonna argue back that penis can be
funny okay yeah
hey maybe people maybe they should start
using more medical terms i'm playing a
revolver sucking on a labia i'm supreme
when i pull back her clitoral hood
you hit a certain level like if you have
too much sex like
you just start talking and acting in a
way that
most people can't relate to right i
think when you [ __ ] a lot you get away
with saying crazy stuff yeah you have
like a new level of confidence i had two
friends that
you know they were hot dudes and
they were like kind of
just casually like dropping stories
about like the results of them [ __ ]
and then one of them goes i remember
that remember that
like that lady that paid our rent
and they started laughing like oh yeah
that was crazy i'm like what do you got
what i'm sorry run that back
and then my boy was like oh yeah
now i was i was [ __ ] this milf and um
we [ __ ] and i just told her like we're
kind of short on the rent and
boom
rent payment
she just sent it to me right there i was
like
like he was doing only fans before only
fans yeah right right
with that sugar baby
no it wasn't even that like cub or
whatever it wasn't even like a built up
relationship though yeah
i mean yes yes it is like a sugar baby
thing but that is crazy to just dick
someone down and then they're like oh
i want you to come back yeah
i want you around for another month why
don't you take
it it's a crazy thing so i think when
you [ __ ] a lot you just you can say
crazy stuff and wear crazy [ __ ] yeah
because there's no like
there's no there's no one to like check
you yeah there's no yeah there's cause
you don't need to do anything no or
prove anything anymore so it's like
mgk for example okay well pivot
i'm just saying he probably [ __ ] a lot
yeah
you know and he's like okay i'm gonna
wear fishnets all the time yeah i guess
it doesn't matter if it's one or
multiple people if you're [ __ ] a lot
yeah i guess i lean i err more on the
[ __ ] a lot of people side
makes you weird because
there's no sense of rejection like
that's where the confidence comes from
to wear crazy stuff like that doesn't
matter all the all these like
conservative guys that got mad at harry
styles about the dress they don't
understand yeah that dude has just
[ __ ] a ton yeah yeah now it's just a
game to him you they do the same [ __ ]
yeah they [ __ ] this much
[Laughter]
he just woke up and he's like yeah if i
don't put on a dress yeah it's not even
a game it's like how can i how can life
remain exciting anymore i've done it all
i've done it all i've toured the world
every time i get on stage
you know
men and women are like i can [ __ ]
whoever i want yeah whenever i want yeah
so i'm gonna put on a [ __ ] dress
today yeah just to see what that's like
yeah
it's like it's like prince you like
transcend sexuality exactly
so jack is getting like the first layer
of that yeah yeah yeah he's just
experimenting with things that he can
say yeah like he's like what what
what off-putting [ __ ] can i say right
just you know yeah she's sucking on my
ass cheeks
and you're like what
yeah that'll be the next one
some weird something weird like that
yeah where you're like i can't even
really picture that happening what do
you mean she's sucking on your ass
cheeks
what does that do for you
you know what i mean she going down on
my belly button huh she picked the lint
out my belly button
what
yes i just you know i just make her pick
it out because i can yeah
just you know okay
turn up i'll just put put a little dirt
in there so she has a little something
to find later
what are some other ones girl you a
lesbian romantic yeah
[Laughter]
that's why drake didn't even see that
line as being off-putting at all he
didn't think that [ __ ] was weird he just
you know
yeah
just his eyes are rolled up in his head
what stupid ass thing can i say yeah
yeah because i [ __ ] a lot
why would you write this it doesn't
matter what i say
when are you gonna get that through your
mind i could no matter what i say i'm
gonna go platinum i'm gonna [ __ ] whoever
i want
he's just like learning simlish like
from like in the sims game just
like watch this man i wanted to make
yeah and just you know just walking up
to women in the club just being like
[ __ ] going there
i hung out with drake last night i
couldn't understand a thing he said i
don't know he's drunk or something we
made out for a long time
that [ __ ] was crazy how did he what did
he say to you to get to
get him to make out or get you to make
it he was just like
no i don't think he said a single
english word actually i think he spoke
in reverse yeah yeah
just one yeah
so i don't know man whatever you know
ladies chime in you know let us know
it's gonna be an overwhelming amount of
comments on this episode that are like
you don't know anything about periods
and you don't know anything about
our consumption of jack harlow but that
said i think that they're going to agree
with me that semen is unreasonable yes
the word semen is unlistenable i think
yes in isolation the word semen is
unlistenable but as a as a complete
package
i think jack is still winning
yeah yeah totally absolutely he's still
winning but yeah yeah no and i'm really
looking forward to his album i think
it's gonna be great i can see it as well
that
i think he's doing everything right
right seaman is an unlistenable line
yeah okay actually i'm gonna go one step
further and say it's almost good to put
out a song that is so jarring like this
why
because
now people are talking about you yeah
yeah gets under their skin this song is
[ __ ] booty he's like i know yeah
cause that's exactly what i'm gonna get
from it people shaking s
when he says that line at whatever
festival he does next
and every girl there is like sweet sweet
that's when every dude is gonna go oh
[ __ ]
[Music]
this is not for us
what about ejaculate yo jack uh use a
jack use that dude you know kind of
plays with the name i just thought of a
horrible one
you know i'm coming the way they say
ejaculate
like
[Laughter]
just something there
there's something there
[Laughter]
see i could totally see him saying yeah
yeah and that's unlistenable until
you're in the club like
jack
jack you lit
you see me coming the way jack you lit
something like that